[Music]
could you walk us through what a hold me
tight conversation is
a whole big tight conversation
very briefly is a bonding conversation
the tricky part is that as adults some
of us have never seen this conversation
so it's a dance that is foreign to us
we've never had it with our own parents
we've never had it with siblings we've
never had it with previous lovers
and we get married or we get committed
to a partner
and
it's reasonable that we don't know how
to go there
because many of us it's just not a drama
that we've ever seen enacted a hold me
tight conversation
is where one person is able to
open up and reach for the other person
and share vulnerabilities
talk about their needs and fears in a
way that pulls the other person close
it helps the other person reach back and
respond
could you give any examples of phrasing
or questions
or guidelines you provide that would be
i i know i would love to know and i
suspect others would too well when you
don't trust you don't feel safe and
you've never seen a hold me tight
conversation the way it usually goes
just naturally as human beings i catch
myself doing this with my husband if i'm
upset about something
like he's been going to bed very early
and that means that we don't have our
snuggle time we don't have our little
chat time okay and it doesn't seem to
bother him at all but it doesn't bother
him this isn't happening so this will go
on for a couple of weeks and
even though i'm doing this work there's
a certain point where i start to get
self-protective and i start to blame him
in my head and i say he's always too
busy he's got his lists he's got lists
that's what he and he's a man and he's
got lists and all he cares about is his
list of tasks and he's just into problem
solving and he doesn't think about me at
all and this dialogue will go in my head
so i turn to him and i say
you're going to bed very early
these days listen to my voice it's the
emotional music
he says no no
because he hears the threat in my tone i
say yes you are and you've been going to
bed for weeks and i guess it doesn't
matter to you that we're not having
those close moments uh listen to me i
mean i'm on the attack
and we are acutely sensitive as human
beings to signs of rejection or
abandonment by the people we love
acutely sensitive that's how we're wired
so he hears that he's blown it he hears
it that i'm rejecting him i'm telling
him he's done something wrong so he says
i don't want to talk about this right
now
i say oh let me guess you have to go to
bed because you're so tired
right so we're off right okay that is
the typical demand withdraw demand
defend
dialogue that you'll see in a distressed
couple
and it's totally predictable
you can also have it with your kids i
can remember a glorious argument i had
in starbucks with my adolescent son that
was just a perfect example of the way
distressed couples talk to each other so
i'm blaming and pointing fingers and
he's rolling his eyeballs and basically
telling me what a dreadful mother i am
so you can have it with anyone but with
partners it's very predictable and it
has everyone feeling completely
threatened and unsafe
and unable to dance together if you
shift that into a hold me tight
conversation
the way it would go
is that i would be
more able to tune into my own needs
more aware of my own needs accepting of
my own needs
and i would realize
oh
i'm really missing those conversations
with john we've been married for 32
years we're both very strong people so
it's been quite an adventure so i think
oh i'm missing those relationships with
john
and maybe he doesn't miss them
and oh that makes me feel really somehow
anxious and uncomfortable if he doesn't
miss them
because
the big question in love relationships
is are you there for me do i matter to
you can i count on you
maybe those conversations don't matter
to him but they really matter to me so i
am aware on a different level
of me and i'm specifying that scares me
a bit that maybe these conversations
don't matter to him i can tune into my
own emotions then i take the risk and
reach for him and say to him i'm open
i say to him
you know what we haven't been having our
usual talks
late at night
and
somehow it doesn't look like you miss
them
and
somehow that makes me feel
kind of really sort of uncomfortable you
know it's almost feels
like i'm i'm not sure that that
closeness matters to you and
so i could get angry about it but
actually what's happening is
it sort of scares me a bit because i
need those conversations now i've talked
about my fears and my needs
i can only do that if i have some sort
of model that it's okay to do that that
that doesn't mean i'm a wimp
or mentally ill or weak
or pathetic from my point of view it's
strength to do that and that's what we
teach and it's strength to do that
and that's what securely attached people
can do they can reach from a position of
vulnerability so i say that to him
and that pulls him he says
oh
you're right
yeah
um yeah
i really like those i really i do i do
want those conversations so i've just
been so exhausted and i've been doing
this and i haven't wanted to tell you
how stressed out i am
so then it becomes reciprocal i say
oh
i didn't know that you were so stressed
out about this decision we've made and
that it's taking up all your energy and
you're worried about it so then we start
to have
an open responsive engaged conversation
where we can share vulnerabilities
comfort each other and you're literally
better at tuning in to each other and i
think that's because when i feel
safe i can tune into you
when i think about the people i can
dance with in tango really well
it's the people i feel emotionally safe
with and i know that there's no mistakes
because mistakes don't matter we're just
playing
then i relax i'm in my body i tune into
their cues and we move together
naturally so that's kind of what happens
and it's a hold me tight conversation
and it's
sort of cascades
each time you have this conversation
it's
your nervous system goes ah
this is comfort this is home this is
safety this is this is what i need
and you see your partner as a resource
you see your partner as somebody who can
provide this safety comfort caring
reassurance
social support if you want to use a
psychological formal term for it you see
your partner as this person and your
partner
connects and you know how to do this
dance this dance is innately
rewarding
it creates joy in people you don't have
to persuade people to keep doing it like
going to the gym or meditation or their
communication skills
people will do this once they know how
to do it
they'll keep doing it and that's why i
think we get good follow-up results
because once you start having these
conversations
and
it's very moving sometimes to see
people's
response like people
will start to cry and say things like
when they discover these hold me tight
conversations people will say
i'm thinking of one man who said
i never knew that you could talk to
somebody like this
i never knew
that you could
ask for these things and that she wants
me to be vulnerable to her i never knew
that i never saw that growing up i
didn't know people did that
and then he wept
and he turned to the therapist and said
i've been alone all my life haven't i
and that
what attachment science tells us is that
emotional isolation is toxic for human
beings
i mean we found out that in the pandemic
but
we still don't get it i wish we would
get it on a different level it's toxic
for human beings it's not who we are and
when people start to have these
hold me tight conversations
all kinds of amazing things happen they
don't just understand how relationships
can be and how you can shape
relationships don't have to just have
them happen to you you can shake love
they understand something very deep
about themselves
couples grow each other in safe
relationships couples grow each other
i watch
severely traumatized people learn to
trust another human being by having
these homie tight conversations with
their partner
and it changes everything
because they have a secure place in life
for the first time they feel seen
they feel accepted they feel held
and once you feel seen accepted and held
there's a natural
human
growth process that happens
attachment or science is all about
development of the personality there's a
natural growth process so we tune into
that natural process in the whole me
tight conversation
and those conversations predict
over study after study after study after
study
those conversations predict success in
eft
they predict more secure bonding they
predict better sex
more sexual satisfaction in couples they
predict
any sort of
measure of
good positive functioning you can
imagine those bonding conversations
predict all the good results we get in
eft and they predict results that follow
up
you